let's uh let's actually talk about the
lead story we didn't get to yet and um
actually did we yeah we did not because
uh i
i do you know a lot of people don't
actually jump in until after the fact so
then we have this like
you know we'll title this video and then
people will be like did i miss it yeah
and so it's like
we're just kidding yeah we kind of just
ran with it there
but now we can actually get into we can
expand upon this like psychosis
okay where it's you know it's logical
conclusion i didn't know it was an air
force
sergeant go ahead and read it so people
know what i'm talking about so this
story is from abc7
air force sergeant arrested on suspicion
for killing of deputy in santa cruz
county
i i remember i'm pretty sure uh i heard
the story apparently it was like some
explosion happened yeah an id i guess
yeah and then apparently it was a dude
killing cops
now what's crazy is this guy he's like
they say he's posted libertarian stuff
they say that he's posted about antifa
not
with them but he's also referenced like
the rise of fascism and resisting it and
explicitly said he was like wanting to
kill cops or whatever and now they're
investigating whether or not he was
connected to the attack in oakland where
a van pulled up and killed these cops
dang so let's check out this story it's
from
abc7 they say the abc 7i team
has new information about the suspect in
the death of 38 year old santa cruz
county sheriff sergeant damon
gutzwiller the ship's department
identified the suspect as 32-year-old
stephen carrillo of ben
lomond the fbi is investigating whether
carrillo is also responsible for the
shooting at the oakland federal building
that killed security officer pat
underwood and injured his partner on may
29th
security cameras caught this white van
as the side door opened up and gunfire
erupted
saturday's incident began when someone
spotted carrillo in a white van with
weapons and bomb making materials
sheriff's duty deputies followed the van
back to his ben lamont house
where authorities say he ambushed
officers firing on them and throwing
explosives
killing sergeant-godswiller man brutal
he bolded in a white sedan
hitting another officer a female deputy
was on the radio when it happened you
can hear her scream
oh goodness shortly after his arrest
carrillo may have revealed a motive for
the attack
during his arrest he shouted at officers
this is what i came here to fight i'm
sick of these
goddamn police he gets garbled but then
mentions police use of force
carrillo yelled listen the i-team is
confirmed
carrillo is an active duty military
police officer
a staff sergeant assigned to the 60th
security force squadron
out of travis air force base carrillo
entered the air
force in february 09 after completing
basic training and security force
training at lackland air force base in
texas
he worked as a recruiter in brentwood
before going to travis air force base in
2018 according to an air force spokesman
they have a they have a recruiting
station in brentwood brentwood's super
wealthy that's my understanding maybe
i'm wrong
last place i expect them to recruit an
air force spokesperson also notes
carrillo completed phoenix raven
training which includes cross-cultural
awareness
legal considerations embassy operations
airfield survey techniques explosive
ordnance awareness
aircraft searches and unarmed
self-defense he was deployed
to kuwait for four months in 2019 and
received the air force achievement medal
for that deployment his former
colleagues are baffled that in effect a
cop would target cops
his friend justin earhart is a retired
air force military police officer it
just breaks my heart
the officers who were impacted and their
families were supposed to be on the same
side
erhart told us he spoke with carrillo
just a month ago about his plans to
retire from the service
he was looking forward to getting out of
california but there was there was
nothing even brought up in a negative
light about anything with police at all
grillo's facebook page has been taken
down but i captured his profile picture
that lists him as libertarian and his
friends have been sending me screenshots
from the past month
it's clear carrillo was growing
increasingly upset about police
excessive use uh
police excessive force june 5th he wrote
who need antifa to start riots when you
have the police to do it for you
just minutes before yesterday's killing
he posted this from the holocaust museum
the early warning signs of fascism on
his facebook page on may 31st crillo
reposted a meme that said
i'll never let racist white people make
me forget about the dope white people i
know exist i love y'all
the post includes fist emojis of
different skin tones and both of the
whites and the meme were crossed out
carrillo wrote the only race that
matters the human race
justin earhart tells us carrillo was
also having a hard time with his wife's
suicide in 2018.
she was an air force airman first class
found dead in an off-base hotel in south
carolina
a lot of regret i think was that was
there and it was just challenging for
him
but even with all of that none of the
people that i talked to who were
stationed with him even once thought
this would happen at all
wow so i'll leave it there but the one
thing i really want to highlight in the
story
the rapid radicalization of this guy
yeah how quickly
he went into the police anti-police
rhetoric
these this antifa line of thinking
saying it's fascism showing that the
warning signs
that warning signs for fascism thing is
not even real
it's like really it's just a souvenir
someone made and they made it i can't
remember
i think it was about obama or something
yeah it's just what
what people do they do this all the time
they'll write something like
here's what the people claimed was you
know the rise of nazi germany and then
they'll just make random points
like has dog drinks water you know
whatever and then the next person is
like see
this is a list that proves that i'm
right one of the things they did
recently is that donald trump held up
the bible
and so somebody photoshopped an image of
hitler holding the bible with
it's trump's hand and then people
believe it and they're like whoa
oh they photoshopped that i mean i saw
it i was like what a photoshop this is
silly
it was actually him waving or something
it was hitler like waving they photoshop
it and people believe it
so people started seeing this like
holocaust museum
thing that some political person made to
attack i think it was
obama to be honest and
he believes it and he radicalizes well i
feel like this would be a person that
they would want to target like he was
obviously crushed like i guess his his
wife
killed herself yep it's like i don't
know why we you know i'm
i i don't know the circumstances there
but clearly he was
distressed and you know it's like they
you see someone like that and they
probably
steer it into wherever they want reminds
me of uh
i use they but i'm talking about antifa
reminds me of the dark knight
okay when uh two-face now all mangled
yep
captures the cop or whatever and then
batman says this is the kind of
you know sick mind the joker praise upon
yep this dude's wife
kills herself now he's angry he's
confused he doesn't understand
he's struggling with it that is a really
great that's exactly it right and then
along comes this narrative
nailed it that gives him something to
like keep going
yeah and it's the wrong thing and it
made him go and turn
on his own people and
like i wonder you know what let's
i wonder i want to go back to the
beginning of the story because i'm
curious as to why it is
they followed his van back to his house
because he had weapons in it and bombing
materials and then he attacked them
he had a white van with weapons and
bombing materials that's why i think
they're like was he involved in in
oakland
so this guy was radicalized and
radicalized fast how come nobody's
talking about that how come how come
this story isn't
running you know top of the line cnn
msnbc fox news
because it's the other side yeah this
guy's clearly antifa
and i don't mean antifa in the sense
that he's like part of a group
like rose city or something like that
he's very clearly following their line
of radicalization
and i wouldn't be surprised if it turns
out somebody was whispering in his ears
somebody found him started saying stuff
to him dude i'll tell you what man
rich people i know a ton of rich people
they're very susceptible to this okay
and i think the people that i know who
have fallen for fall into this stuff
it's because their parents were
neglecting them so i know some people
ridiculously wealthy
their parents were always working yeah
and so they had very little
connection yeah and then what happens
when
someone some one of these ideologues
extremists
gives them time at the time of day and
starts whispering in their ear
seeing this person's got money they can
fund us they can they can help us do all
these things
yeah and now all of a sudden this person
feels like people care about them and
they're getting that attention
they craved they eat it up it's so easy
yeah this story is this story is rather
freaky to me
because i think it has a lot to do with
facebook i've been talking about this
for a while man that
there there was one website that
literally only posts videos of police
brutality
right it's like well yeah dude if you
watch nothing but that you're gonna go
insane
that's true yeah dude it's a good point
and then what happens is
there was a period on facebook where
nothing but police brutality man
i know some people who made a ridiculous
amount of money just posting videos of
police brutality
it was gold mine because everybody would
always share it
yep that's true and then what happens
when a crazy guy whose wife is dead sees
it
and he has the means the knowledge the
ability this is crazy you know what's
really crazy about this he was active
duty
yeah yeah i'm pretty sure they said uh
no that's what you said that's what they
said
right in 2019 so yeah i guess so huh
well i think they say
uh right up top uh what does it say it
says it i thought
did you do they are investigating it
yeah i'm pretty sure it said that he is
active duty suspect in the death
i don't know where it said but well i'll
just type it in
there it is yup they confirmed he's an
active duty military police officer wow
so we were talking about the other day
when they were chanting
uh the black lives matter people were
chanting i'm black and i'm proud
and the the one you know i don't know if
he was an mp or if he was army or
whatever he was in dc
was chanting it under his breath too
right and i'm like listen man
i know we got freedom of speech but
there's a reason why you can't do that
and i'm i think that's really dangerous
when you've got ideologues
on the line this dude turned you know
what i mean
yeah like he's supposed to be that he's
part of that system
i've heard some really crazy stories
about ideologues
who get you know people who get
brainwashed and manipulated by
extremists
like there's a way to do things man and
they're absolutely convinced that
there's no such thing as reform
it's like dude everything that we've
accomplished was reform like civil
rights wasn't a revolution bro
right it was a reform so like all of the
great accomplishments of the united
states
all of the amendments that's just reform
yeah the amendments
are reform yeah literally reforms but
they want to burn it all to the ground
there's a funny meme they're like when
when someone says you know health care
isn't working we need more money
you know schools aren't working we need
more money the fire department isn't
working let's increase its budget
the police isn't working shut her down
defund them yeah it doesn't make sense
does it no
no well maybe more money doesn't help
either right you could you could argue
that the money wouldn't help either but
i just think it's it's ideological
i think they don't want the police for a
reason i don't think they like the
constitution
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm if you want
to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you